hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast discovery of biomarkers
predictive of anti-cancer drugs response
and pre clinical setting presented by
dr. Benjamin obtains an assistant
professor at the Princess Margaret
Cancer Centre at University of Toronto
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab route and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box to locate it
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appear on the screen our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits just
click on that continuing education
credit tab located on the top right hand
corner of your presentation window and
follow those processes for obtaining
your credits without further ado please
join me in welcoming our presenter today
dr. Benjamin F Gaines I will now turn
the presentation over to him welcome dr.
ed kids thank you very much for ending
the Asian and I'm very glad to speak
about the research we do in the lab
regarding the biomarker discovery from
preclinical model system Sam beederman L
Kings on working the Princess Margaret
Cancer Centre University of Toronto and
today we'll discuss about the various
ways to discover all markers for cancer
so as you know we are pretty good now at
not only identifying the whole loss of
cancer in terms of pathways that are
relevant and sometimes essential for
cancer to grow but we're also pretty
good at designing compounds to target
those pathways
so or you could think of the recent
immunotherapy and to block you know
resistance or are the park inhibitors
for instance so we have this large
portfolio of compounds and can so whole
March and are the targets
however we those those are markers those
therapy sorry only are only effective on
a subset of the patients roughly around
five to twenty percent of of the patient
for the path therapies so the big
question is how do we know we're therapy
we should go we should give to each
individual patients and that's the whole
premise for precision medicine how do we
match the drug for Asian deployed
patients coming to the plate and one way
to do it is to better understand the
genomic landscape of the patient tumors
to predate for given drug whether the
patient would be a responder or
non-responder here's the problem so
despite large investments in major
cancer centers only 18 to 39 percent of
the patient actually benefit from this
rather expensive and time-consuming
approach and you can see here for the
biggest studies including impact compact
clinical trials in principle smarter and
you can see that the number or the
proportion of patients for which we
found an actionable genomic aberration
meaning that we could predict which drug
could be very effective given an
aberration observed in in the patient
tumor and this proportion is rather low
for the vast majority for the majority
of patients we cannot find any
actionable aberration in the patient
tumor and that is due to multiple
factors one of them is that usually
follows on genotype mass clinical trials
we use very small sequencing and gene
panel focus on mutations and copy number
variations in protein coding genes on
these you the usually range from 50
oncogenes have up to 500 on and that's
obviously limit our ability
to explore the genomic landscape of
patient tumors another problem and maybe
the main problem is that we actually
know very little about the relationship
between the genomic variation and the
therapy response even if we see genes
aberrations genes are mutated or genes
that are deleted wrong inside in a given
patient tumors tumor we cannot really
predict which one would be the most
efficient for most of the compounds that
are used on even in clinical settings so
that's a major issue that my lab is
trying to tackle using preclinical data
I'll go through different biological
materials that one could use for bomber
discovery they are mainly classified in
three categories he in situ on data
which is basically the patient tumor and
the in vivo data those are animal models
including patient rugs and graft and
genetic engineered mouse models and the
in vitro models but our consists of
immortalized stem cell lines
two decent lines as well as the newer
model 3d organics and derived from
patient tumor cells so each of those
samples or materials have the pros and
cons so obviously if you want to predict
a good ball marker if you want to I
don't find new novel gene drug
associations on patient data are
definitely the most relevant data to use
however it's very hard to collect such
samples you need usually you need to do
it in a clinical setting you need to
collect samples you need to provide
samples for the genomic operation and
then you need to follow the patient for
their clinical order there are many
aspects that are problematic with this
approach not only you need you need to
follow if it's principal so it's it
could be eliminated when you wanna test
component or another proof don't use me
do it
you're limited to approve drugs on
samples of high-definition rare for some
diseases and even for common disease
it's very costly and lengthy to organize
the people trial so even so those those
samples and resulting data are the most
relevant and also the most difficult to
collect if you go a little bit step
further from patient tumors and you take
patient materials and graph those tumor
cells into an animal model such as a
mouse model then you can get a good
model that will recapitulate somehow I'm
partially the the response in the
patient so it's not perfect those models
still like major components of the
tumors in the patient including part of
the microenvironment and a functional
immune system however and they also
vehicles a lengthy to use so you can
screen a few dozen strokes but it's hard
to screen a hundred drugs on a thousand
of those animal models so it's rather
medium to low to medium throughput this
platform do those kind of samples are
amenable for low to medium through the
drug screening on the other end of the
spectrum you have the individual models
so there is barely any ethical issues
using those they're very cheap and high
throughput for our drug screening we can
use robotic platforms to screen hundreds
of drugs on thousands of some arms and
you can screen both approved and
experimental drugs so those are the
advantages of
DiPietro however they're pretty far away
from the patient tumors they actually
like many many features of the tumors
including this from including the
functional immune system but also
growing in a very rich medium which
makes them which makes the response to
therapy sometimes we're different for
what is observed in the patients however
we got tons and tons of data from those
in vitro models so the usual way to
discover biomarker is first to start in
vitro disease G because we can generate
a lot of data then we go to preclinical
trials where we take some candidates
biomarkers and test them in a series of
in a cohort of animal models and then
finally we test those mark biomarkers
that are been discovered in vitro
validating in animal models we finally
tell them in the patient with this one
two and three our team of trials so I'm
going to focus today on the biggest
source of data for markers in clinical
settings using those in vitro models so
you can imagine that if you have a large
kind of cancer lines originating from a
lot of tissue types you can provide
those immortalized cancer cell lines
what extensively you have a lot of
materials to use for profiling so people
have already profiled that expression
the köppen appropriation gene expression
methylation protein abundance for all
those cell lines in addition to those
and genomics data you want to provide
those demands on pharmacologically what
you want to generate is what we call a
drug dose response curves where you test
several concentration on the first steps
on the x axis of the drug dose response
curves and you look at the cell
viability on the y axis and you you're
looking for drugs that affect viability
one concentrations increased so here you
see the red and the green curve on the
top right you can see that this green
curve is actually a straight horizontal
line meaning that the drug is doing
nothing to effect it doesn't inhibit the
growth of the cells or the purple curve
you see that is decreasing with respect
to increasing concentration so district
is definitely having some and both
nugatory effect on documents online
so by combining the genomic data and the
pharmacological data that's how you can
do the biomarker discovery we call those
data from academics data as they combine
post promoters of profiles and gently
profiles so if you consider that
eugenics profiles are labeled as X and
you drug dose response goes actually the
thermo types to try to try to predict
labeled as Y the biomarker is actually
this function of the genomics that allow
you to predict the phenotype so this
function f of X is actually your market
could be a univariate function using
only one mutation let's say one copy
number variation or it could be a milky
varied as well as multi model combined
gene expression in mutation and open
information for instance of medical
genes
so what be you know so far is that those
Jimi's data not only there are very high
dimensional dimensional you have many
many genes that you can focus you can
measure and gene expression could be an
aberrational mutation for instance but
they also ported notices so here you see
are two examples one gene on the left
side as extremely inconsistent between
two studies so GG assistance or
legitimate drug sensitivity cancer it's
a large screening they said from the
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute in UK
and the other one is to cancel saline
encyclopedia for the joy and the Jamie's
data injury that the Broad Institute
award the formulation of profiles
profiles
be generated by an artist in Boston so
here you can see that for the first gene
on the left on the gene expression
actually completely uncorrelated between
the two acids and most striking is
actually the fact that engineer see
these genes is never expressed you know
a lot hundreds of salons well for the
same sunlight in Sicily you see a wide
range of expression and they both use
the same microwave platform or very
similar matrix chip so you cannot really
explain that
a bias in the technology so there is
really something inherently noisy about
about that G in terms of gene expression
on the right side on the other hand you
can see that between the two studies not
only the scale of the expression matches
very closely but you can also see that
the two expression extremely created
between the two dead set so among the
25,000 protein coding genes there are
some genes are extremely created
extremely robust across studies while
others are extremely unstable and noisy
so that's something that was known and
that's something that we can somehow
take into account when we do the
biomarker discovery what was less of
user is the fact that the phenotype
itself the drug response for a given so
line is actually the process of a is
actually the results of a very complex
and noisy process so there is a lot of
noise in the phenotype phenotypic data
as well here you can see our two
examples of of some lines that are very
discordant curse on between GDS G and
Sicily so one day is that the get design
is is defined or is of this measure as
being highly resistant while in the
other datasets measure to be quite
sensitive so in those cases is very hard
for a machine learning approaches subtle
approach to I don't find a biomarkers if
the status of the Saline comes of
sensitivity and resistance and suddenly
switch between are between studies so
that's something that is not very well
known in the field and in statistics and
machine learning even so we're pretty
good at dealing with the noise in the
input features it's actually hard to
deal with noise in the output or the
phenotypic features so this field is
actually a very very active field with a
lot of data being shared over the years
it all started with the young and 60
panel of 16 salons as part of the drug
and detrimental therapy program and the
NCI where they screened is more panel
surmise for
in CD version Bob drugs up to 200,000
compounds with a key 60,000 drugs for
high quality data and you can see that
Japan followed with their own and 60
live program and a series of other data
set that have been published on the
years either from from our companies or
research institutes like the Wellcome
Trust Sanger Institute in Austin so it's
a very active tool we are access to a
lot of data and because people using
real-life summaries that are
commercially available we actually have
a lot of overlap posters different
studies which opens very interesting
I've been your research when it comes to
training and validate on biomarkers as
well as written consistency across
datasets even so those data being shared
on to the best ability of the day are
generators of the authors of the papers
it's actually there is no consensus in
terms of some of the basic elements of
those pharmacokinetics data for instance
unser lines can be identified using on
different names and there is no
standardized nomenclature for cancer
survivor' instance so we decided to make
the cell line of the salon identifier
identifier some system across dataset
using new relatively new platform for
users
who's a which is a very extensive and
progressive database of saline and
notations so from this we could rename
the semis on consistently across dataset
to maximize your overlap even so if you
think that filling is aligned to be
tricky to curate you should definitely
take a look at the drug I don't fires
it's even harder nobody really agreed on
the way to identify drugs in those data
set where people sometimes use a brand
brand name or a company name on the
molecular
molecule name so we decided to take all
those drugs and manually annotate them
using our well-established classifiers
such as
Khem identifier in cheeky Kimball all
the smiles the scripture of the compound
and to and that allowed us to do not
only exact matching posted as a below
surface imaging to see whether on some
compounds could be very similar and be
considered as chemical replicates so it
was a really used process operation of
annotation that took us more than four
years in the lab but no we built a
resource for former projects that allows
for communication platform for form of
measurements and meta analysis so we not
only build a software package but also
really soft and environments of virtual
machines with all the dependencies as
well as a more recent web application to
allow people to busy mindless data so we
present those resources in the next few
slides and we hope that the series of
software tools really help the community
better minders on a large scale pretty
lot from our extensive to do better
biomarkers hope in the future so from
our GX first um it's all packaged as
available on our computer and has been
published in 2016 by our medics and the
idea is that we downloaded all the
Jimmy's data we process them with verse
number five lines then we did the same
we did the same thing with the on drug
response data that was a little bit more
difficult because the each study would
mean Easter fire this salon viability
with respect to concentration and
measurements in a different way so we
had there was a lot of work to do to
build a spec for each study but the most
important part is actually to merge
those two data the data sources the
genomics data as well as the
pharmacological data and use the same
annotations
across all the pieces of data which
means that we created a so my name as
well as the drug names so there were
over consistent across different states
the beauty is that you don't have to
care about this anymore
you can directly download the fully
created object that contains all those
pieces of data and they let me check for
for integrity so we call it from a
cassette or piece of short so you can
download that that data set I know your
we provide in from our projects a series
of convenient functions to to do very
basic analysis such as plotting the drug
dose response curves modeling and
summarizing that workers response curve
with something like ic50
which is the concentration you need to
be fifty percent of of cell growth or
DEA or the AAC area about third row
space monsters as a summary of the
resistance of sensitivity phenotype
forgiving someone we also a function to
easy expectancy expression to average
the replicase so finally you get all the
matrices or the data you need for your
biomarker discovery pipeline we also
provide basic functions to do you never
a biomarker discovery controlling for
tissue type as well as batch batch
effects in those datasets so those are
very basic function to explore and do
basic analysis from those datasets
however many of our collaborators were
are not very accommodation savvy so they
don't really like the idea of studying
our terminal studying our session to
mind or senses we decided to build a
website about application to allow users
to easily mind those data we now have
seven datasets in there that contains
more than 16-hundred you need some lines
and more than half a million drug dose
response curves so those that are pretty
massive but because they are being
created carefully now you can look at
those data in a unified way so if you
burn from our PDB dossier you can type a
silly name or drug name or combination
of ass alignment row and you'll see
different types of information about
both from those big for market
reinstates so I'll go through some of
the function keys here so if you type a
silly name such
a four a five four nine which is the
line answers for mine we can directly
see in which studies to summarize
opinions so we have seven studies on
time from the Royal Institute the
Wellcome Trust those are the biggest one
but also for some front from some farm
equipment from a companies such as
Novartis of Genentech and you can see
that here for instance this line has
been extensively screen in in a project
or an obstacle CT RPG tube which is a
cancer response separating poro
at the road institute it has been
screened for more than 500 drugs if you
type of drug on the other hand such as a
CD 6 2 4 4 which is a negative from
AstraZeneca we can see that this work
has been also spinning many medical
studies and you can see the new growth
so nice in speed against that drug in
each study so those are valuable
information to know which data set might
be most interesting for you now the most
interesting part is when you start
typing a sign name and a drug name so
what happens then is that you have in
one click you have access to all the
drug dose response curves for that
specific a pair of drug and cell line in
medical studies so here it's a very
typical example of curves that are not
particularly consistent prostate so you
can see that depending on the studies of
a wide range of sensitivity with one of
the replicas of GDS C claiming that that
cell is very very sensitive to the MEK
inhibitor while the other replicas
actually claim the distance is quite
resistant and you can see that yo
replicates what you see top-2 a bit
closer to each other are still quite a
bit of discrepancy and the CC early data
set designer work is promoters of data
report somewhat an intermediate
sensitivity so many of the curves are
consistent some are inconsistence that's
an example of inconsistent curves but
until really allow you to observe all
the cities at once
to assess yourself the consistency
of those from original data so another
aspect of the study is that you can
easily access or because summary
statistics so those are basically
summarization matrix of the purpose
response curves so here you can see that
we are pre computed the area above the
drape of responsibility ic50 ec50 viens
and an order matrix that have been
published so that that resource has been
published indicators research last year
and is freely available so again I'm
going there don't load the data are you
interested in and explore 7 large-scale
projects data sets the beauty of the
creation is that we can actually look at
many of the studies at once and
understand where what's the what's the
overlap about those two so for instance
if you look at the cell lines overlap
across five data sets you can see that
there there are keys to a 300 bucks that
has been screened in for data sets so
this part is full enough set bud and it
basically report on any kind of of
overlap for for a given set of states
represented by the dark dots at the
bottom so 307 spinning for dancer that's
quite an impressive number on to the cap
consistency for instance and same goes
for for the drugs if you look at a drug
that are being screened in medical
studies you can see that there are
several drugs
the dietary screening all the data sets
so again a lot of chemical a lot of
roughly cares for those chemical
perturbations
across multiple independent states which
makes it very interesting for biomarker
discovery however as I said on my we
have spent quite a bit of time to look
at the consistency of those data
Felicita genomic level as well as a
pharmacological level and you may have
you may have seen this this paper
published in 2013 and the photo paper
published in 2016 where we actually said
to our computer
to be studies ccle gese to
quantitatively assess we can get that
from the title that the data were are
surprisingly inconsistent so if you take
all the on the replicates the biological
replicates within within those studies
and if you complete the HTV area above
the Pharos response curves and the
computer difference between AC across
replicates you end up with with a
distribution like this where a lot of
the replicates have actually very very
small data which is very good because it
means that replicates were very very
consistent however there was there was a
small proportion of replicates that
filled in the sense that the difference
in AC is pretty large so if you if you
look at this distribution and you see
that they see greater than 0.2 it's
actually indication that it's unlikely
to come to come out from a replicate if
the Delta AC is more than 0.2 it's
indicated that and the turtles response
on occurs are quite different so if we
do that for all the replicates that we
have in our from academia web
application you can see that there is
globally there is quite the data are
quite consistent across the clips so
here we decided to use two metrics to
assess the consistency one is called the
CI the compromise index what it does it
takes every pair of of cell lines and
see whether two studies or two where P
caves could Granderson lines the same
way so the is it's a generalization of
the area under the ROC curve so here you
can see that the converse index for drug
because across the study is estimated
around
0.74 we expect the corners index of 0.8
to be to represent
consistent data so here we're a little
bit below which is which is a bit
disappointing so we decided to dig into
the nature of the data and see how we
can deal with the noise and increase
that that consistency and we came up
with what we called the MCI to modify
conference index then actually taken
from the notion yes a to increase the
consistency of the data so I will
explain in the next slide
our what MC is exactly but you can
already see here that if you apply this
new matrix and then you get a
consistency or compromise across around
$0.99 which is what we expected from
those high-quality are far more
difficult profiling data so what is MCI
so imagine that you have two of the case
and on the x-axis you have the area
under the the area above the dose
response therefore if you get one and
you have the same on the y-axis for a
ticket to in the ideal world those AAC
were perfectly aligned on the diagonal
that would be a perfect publication of
the experiment however it is no use in
those essays so you can imagine that you
end up yourself with a figure
aesthetically like this then I would
consider that the pharmacological world
consider are quite a successful
application expert meaning that the
three sometimes that are highly
resistant there on the bottom left where
the to some lines that are highly
sensitive on the top right of the
scatterplot however if you look at the
confidence index comparing every pair of
sun lines you only get a conference in
texas upon six which is very very close
to the run time case of 0.5 and the
reason for this is that when you do the
conference index even so you can
numerically order the signs that are
highly resistant the noise and yes a
surgeon if you redo the experiment the
one that was slightly more resistant
than the other one could just switch the
order so in that case the yeah say that
if that accurate is not robust enough to
unable to observe those measure those
subtle differences in the resistance
phenotype
however yes it's very good at
discriminating highly resistant versus
fights unsafe so we decided to modify
the conference index to
discard the pears but I extremely close
in terms of AIDS and if you remember the
last blood we found that 95% of the rest
had a delta AC less than 0.2 so we
decided to basically excuse all the
fertile salons that had a data a AC less
than 0.2 which by default and discard
all the pairs involving two resistance
so on so if you do this then you see
that the conference index is jumping
from increasing from zero point six to
zero point eighty six which is much more
reasonable for this replicated
experiment so know that we kind of face
the way we look at consistency across
dataset we actually we do our initial
analysis that we call this nature and
look that idea increasing consistency in
the blue with the blue bars you can see
that that's the pressure constant except
what we publish in 2013 and constancy
however with this new confidence index
you can see that they compromise across
dataset drastically improved with the
majority of the drugs no a crossing is
arbitrary cutoff of zero on eight that
represent high consistency across two
days
so basically what happens here is that
most of the inconsistency happens in
those pairs where the drug dose response
curves are very close to each other and
it doesn't make sense to on a numerical
order them or look at their correlation
however if you look focus on the bigger
difference than those two this tends to
agree much more so that that is
obviously very important when you want
you to that consistency across studies
however it may not really matter much at
the end of the day we generated those
data to find biomarkers so we decided to
use this new matrix to modify contrast
index to see whether we could find some
of the non biomarkers that are used in
the clinic we have a series here of
around 15 unknown Parker so those are
Jane drug associations are being created
that are killed
that have been tested in case of sitting
and some others are treating for a
cessation that being validated again and
again in preclinical settings so you can
see here that with the body part numbers
index we can actually find more than
half of those genes work association
while with the more traditional converse
index we could only find 20% of those so
there is a drastic improvement in our
ability to find now clinically accrued
gene drug Association
so it actually matters a lot when you do
biomarker discovery to make sure that
not only you take into account the
novice India generally stay there but
also the noise in the formality of their
thanks to our former codex platform
including many many data sets that we
can do meta-analysis which means that we
don't have to limit ourselves to the
analysis of the single dataset we can
actually combine many days ourselves to
do more of this power marker discovery
so here's an example of a non bio marker
which is near VB to gene expression as a
pretty far marker of sensitivity to
lapatinib and you can see here that if
you compute the MCI which is represented
by a big order as well as confidence
interval represented by the horizontal
line for single square you can see that
the MCI is actually pretty high for that
for that bar marker with an m7 on 0.72
so again it's a non bio markers to be
expected to see us from single however
we can actually see all the different
data sets behave for this number mark
and interestingly you can see here that
the great study have afraid had a very
high price index almost online while the
crpd to study had a much lower
confidence and s are also still
significant and the reason is very
simple here b b2 is a very good
biomarker in breast cancer so the patent
ibiza is a drug used to treat your baby
positive your - positive breast cancer s
tumors and grazers is a breast cancer
dataset so it's because of eighty and
breast cancer so lines y siguió b2 is a
very large pan cancer data set that
includes actually much less here -
positive breast cancer so much so that's
the reason why in some data center
biomarkers were weak and some others are
markers can be very strong
so in source the mechanism a nurse is
using from our projects will also allow
you to better investigate the nature of
those dead cells so we also so your
review was a non bio markers that will
be wanting to find a new biomarker so
here we discovered that or one the
general one the expression of the gene
or one is actually a pretty good
predictor of sensitivity to by the taxa
so the MCA is a little bit lower than
then for a baby to friends and some of
the MJ's circle 62 however I still
highly significant we don't there is no
known biomarker for architects also that
could be an interesting candidate
however as you can see there is one
dataset with where despite marker is
actually not predictive at all of packet
acts of sensitivity and deaths the GVSU
1000 dataset interestingly GBS is is the
only dataset in our collection that
using the site of sixty from a logical
assay to assess drug response so he was
based on the amount of DNA in the cells
so the amount of gaining the cells are
is used to as a surrogate for some
viability while older as they are using
the KGB generation as a surrogate of
cell viability so here it could be a dis
gene that the relationship of for
constantly depends on the way you assess
and the viability of the cells and it
may actually fill when you come the
amount of DNA so maybe the the the
growth innovation process is slightly
different in the case of packet axial
and the choice of assay is actually very
important so again that's an example how
you can investigate the nature
yes and by looking at your meta analysis
results so we wanted to go further than
just gene expression invitation cup in
appropriation so with a large companion
of the up for market ribbon theta we
decided to focus on the most recent
dataset I really a sequencing data set
that have been released in the last few
years uh namely from the Wellcome Trust
Sanger Institute Genentech from draw to
draw very laboratory as well as ccle so
we had a large amount of a release data
to mine and we decided that that instead
of focusing on your gene expression we
would like to look at the expression of
each nibble transfer order for gene so
as you know alternative splicing is
responsible for the expression of many
other forms for specific genes and we
were wondering whether the expression of
ended up from script could actually
follow better Castlebar markers compared
to overall gene expression that's kind
of an average of the expression
apologizing forms and even so with her
microarray data it's very hard to
quantify the expression of a specific
isoforms erin ASIC is provide is
providing you a very good platform and
with a very good platform to do so so we
use those high quality and easy data to
estimate the expression of each
individual isoforms and I correlate them
with first sensitivities that's a paper
we published that last year
intercommunications so the study design
is the following because we had so many
data set we wanted to do we wanted to
keep a lot of data for our own
independent validation so the way we did
it was to use CC LED DSC and as a
combined training set so we did
meta-analysis
find on biomarkers and cancer across
ccle and gese then we decided to
validate those pan cancer biomarkers
using another girl is accomplished by
genotype the GCSE I the Genentech
someone's pretty initiative and we've
allocated all of those markers there we
also decided to use our sense of a
realistic profiles of breast cancer
songs both from internal operatory as
well as private visible in the East
Indies paper from the University Health
Network and really say and we validate
part of the candidate biomarkers in
breast cancer specifically so I'll
summarize all the results into one one
figure that I found particularly
representative of what's happening here
and in terms of the quality of the bomb
Marceline right idea the number of eyes
upon our markers that had been
discovered in the train set and
validated in cancer a validation set
completely independent one is that in
blue you the biomarkers are gene
specific meaning that only your gene
expression is pretty open for
sensitivity and is validated on if Obama
could be readable at the isoform level
as well as an achieve the overall gene
expression level and we only know that
those biomarkers in purple and you can
see that for the futures that were in
common between CCGs in genetic you can
see that the majority of the eyes upon
specific bone markers on God properly
validated in this independent dataset
and there are a few validated biomarkers
that are both validated that we isoform
level and homology expression level
however there are very little gene
specific biomarkers that code by aided
in in the genetic dataset so that's
basically telling you that ISIF own
expression is actually a very good
source of our markers for our response
actually a better source our market and
Concord expression which is usually
which is used as majority of our native
students nowadays so we here we propose
isoforms as as a better source of market
responses on another aspect of our word
is
not only to aggregate and creatively
these data for for cancer research but
also try to click the results of those
analysis I have much closer to the baby
so the goal here is to basically take
the biomarkers that we found to be
robust across beautiful studies in the
cancer salons and give that information
back to the clinician when they look at
the aberrations in the patient tumor so
it's basically connecting the first
slice of a presentation where I show
that a lot of those patients have no
actionable operation so we don't know
what to do with the aberration we see in
the in their tumors and connect that
that that information with the results
of our clinical from academics on by
markets public eye brands so here we
decided to you see by Apollo as a
platform to connect those printing elbow
markers with the clinical observations
see bio model as you may know is a very
widely used a platform to explore
genomic aberrations mostly mutation in
sin V we can also explore expression and
in that platform
it contains TCGA all the major data set
TCGA the cancer cell line encyclopedia
the gtex data and you can actually look
at the different genes across patients
or you can focus on a given patient and
look at the different genomic
aberrations here it's an example of a
male breast cancer patient where there
is a series of amplification that have
been observed in that patient and
luckily luckily this patient has year
vb2 authentication this is a non bio
marker so we know that education gives
treat that patient with repetitive which
is a EGFR you could be - inhibitor that
patient is very likely to respond so
that's that's an example where there is
an action action of elaboration however
most of the time there is no
operation and that's where we plan to
add another icon on Sebago then we'll
report whether that operation could
could it be a mutation hoping a
vibration on the chip or gene expression
is as the city with drug response in our
large final of cancer so much so you can
imagine that you see this very this
little pill icon and you could click on
it and get information about the drugs
that are associated with that is that
generic aberrations who here again we
took this very simple example of UV
maternal a positive we have to do bb2
limiters in our head assess their post
associated with your baby to gene
expression and amplification so that if
that association was that known by by
the clinicians then the clinician or she
could access on this deformability
resource and get this additional piece
of evidence to help him or her decide
open the treatment of cancer patient
however the major limitation of this
approach is that as as I said earlier
can systemize done for me recapitulate
on the drug response of cancer patients
and I presented me in people model as a
better printable models to model drug
response however because of because of
the constant that the length of of those
animal studies you cannot really speak
very large so however if you want to
body did a few candidate biomarkers it's
actually a platform of choice before you
move to the P so we are no investigating
existing in vivo for ma contributes
datasets and what we observed obviously
is that tumor growth curves are very
noises very similar to the drug dose
response curves they also the source of
an experiment is quite complex to
and that could also be quite noisy so
here you see actually a pretty good
example where under control is going
quite fast with the time on the x-axis
and tumor volume of devices while it the
treatment of that drug is actually very
effectively and you see stable disease
were in regression of disease however a
lot of the curves emission are noisier
than that so a very similar to the in
vitro from academic data you can have to
take it back from the noise in teen
people from our bedroom instead so we
decided to implement a platform very
similar to from Michael Jackson's corpse
even for xenograft evaluation of pert
response so you can see that the
experimental design is actually quite
complicated then for the tensile surmise
that already established that you can
buy from commercial vendors here you can
have most people will have to generate
their own PDX or they will have to
access PD access from other sources like
Jackson that for instance propagates
sheraton of materials in a mouse with
the tumor growing to finally and do some
of the controller and drug treatment
experiments and obviously you could also
provide the patient tumors as well as
the PDX at different passages to to get
a sense of the stability of achievement
operations and very similar to a seller
to the so line on data you can compare
the genomics data from the mouse models
to the phenotypic data which of the two
Merck Oscars for control entry so that's
the source that's it that's a resource
that we are currently developing it is
no publicly available but we are going
to push a paper on by architect very
soon however you can still can already
access and give it a try
to our package that would be submitted
to buy from the cursor very similar to
for market Jackson if stores
created PDX patient drugs and
theta and vert responds and provides a
convenience function to analyze those
data so there was one day December very
perfectly interested in school day
Novartis PDX encyclopedia it's a very
large dataset of a thousand around a
thousand patient drives in aircraft
treated with two dozen some drugs and
they use a very particular design pull
the one by one by one so instead of
doing replicates for each on controlling
treatment arms you actually do only one
control and one arm one Mouse per per
drug so you see it has its limitation
however using the design you were able
to screen a very large number of
patients Enterprise from vehicle tissue
types so as I said it's very similar to
from a projects where you have the
molecular data as well as a tumor growth
on data and you have a series a function
to assess drug response and basic
biomarker discovery so the the type of
phenotypic format logical profiles in ep
for family of its data is quite
different we are not dealing with drug
dose response curves anymore it's
usually one concentration of the drugs
and you monitor the tumor growth over
time and the immutable ways to assess
the sensitivity of a given X and graph
to specific drug and for instance you
can look at the area between the curve
you can detect the angle which is quite
similar but nobody's introduced a
modified with this material which is
what we used the missus criteria are
what we used in the clinic to assess the
clinical response of a patient they
modified it for for the mouse models so
it's based on the best running average
response between on a single curve so
for instance if you have the control
here it would be called progressive
disease as achieved and for this
treatment it's actually a personal
response observation and they have like
four categories including permissive
disease
these partial response in response
bracing regular basis material for most
models we also in the process of
developing new summarization matrix
including well-established months such
as the tumour growth inhibition PGI as
well as new ones such as a method both
on based on motion process modeling and
linear mixed models that require
replication is not amenable to the inner
artist studies where there is only one
curve I've got about four controls and
each treatment drug treatment we define
the limitation of this of this
experimental design that the amount of
data is pretty massive so here this is
just a map of the modified resist
material for all the PD X's or the
breast cancer free access for all the
compounds and combination of compounds
that is great in that state so you can
already see that those that are pretty
rich and and the amount of risk however
one of the challenge in those on PDX for
screening is that Yamano complete
response and partial response actually
pretty low and that's the rationale
either one by one by one experimental
designs that you need to spin a very
large number of indexes have enough
responses to on to biomarker stories so
they kind of traded robustness of TSA
against the number of PD X's particular
screen so we are now investigating those
those data to see whether we can
validate some of our markers
disconcerting tends to so lines into PD
axis but as you can imagine it's a it's
a very time-consuming work and the
number of responses being so it's
actually hard to get it as from stats
about signal from the data so in summary
I sure that there are actually many
piece of marketing data sets are
available and people have been very good
at sharing their from our enormous data
over the years and you can do
tissue-specific as well as banking so
specific
fine consummate analysis to discover
what this biomarker series really with
for Marco GX is one of the ship platform
that allows you to look for our markers
that pallidus across multiple tests
which really Raisa concerns with respect
to those biomarkers you can also now
integrate from academics from multiple
source of data you can combine mutation
copying appropriation and she expression
and we are now integrating methylation
as well as well as protein abundance we
also release political trolls as well as
new annotation to make sure that those
signs and process properly activity so
in summary the resources we've built in
the lab for for biomarkers of great
practical savings of Formica GX that
enables innovative material markers
across medical data sets from academia
that allows you to very easily mind
those data sets in terms of some eyes
and drugs and drug dose response curves
as well as a bar marker so we actually
added the Univerity impression
biomarkers in from a cookie beam we're
in the process of expanding that list is
mutation open appropriation and I think
very interesting in the future we want
to fuse see bubbling from at the db2 a
local clinicians to easily access the
results of the maintenance is done in
for marketing and the hope is that
instead of matching less than 50% less
than 40% of the patient to clinical
first testing fires targeted therapies
we will be able to match up to 70 to 80
percent of those patients and really
build a return investment based on those
large-scale pretty ultimately data
another platform we are still developing
is easy before
large-scale in vivo drug screening
experiment and hopefully that will be on
publish this so at the end I would like
to emphasize again the importance of
research or its ability in all the
biomedical field but in particular in
from academics
the data extremely complex with
different sources of data both
germinates and and pharmacological but
also in terms of analysis pipeline if so
it's good to know and annotate the data
note the source of the data annotated
data priority but is equally important
to actually know exactly what the data
in process and what kind of quality
control and normalization force is
applied and in that context there are
few things we can do to improve the
visibility of our research on the
databases are sharing data and let and
made the data to let other people
scrutinize the data and leverage the
dynamic always and help us to discover
there whether there are errors in those
data and fix them sharing the code to
make sure that it's very well understood
how it's well understood and well
documented altered they'd have been
processed and Cody and Isis have been
done so not only people could find
errors and potentially things in but
also they can reuse it but for other
applications idly shared those on disco
in well-documented easy to install
software packages and ideally also not
only provide the package of the ful
softe environment for people to easily
deploy and the platform and and test the
code with only a few clicks I mean it's
very time consuming to do so but is
definitely worth doing for many aspects
on both in industry and academia
it makes people to onboard faster and in
the lab because they have access to all
the data they can learn faster you see
to integrate feedback from colleagues
and the community or other groups within
the company as they can look at the code
and initially fight mistakes or improve
the code it's also in the academic field
actually makes you it makes it easier to
review Baker when you receive those
Unger reviewers comments up to six
months sometimes are to get back and to
the data and analysis and update those
and you definitely improve the
dissemination of
research output as people who use data
rendered I mean that aspect I'm a
co-founder year MAPC society the massive
analysis and quality control our society
and we're whose mission is really to
promote reversibility and data sharing
in augment of consensus that we like to
thank many people in the lab who've been
crucial and essential in the development
of those platforms including for
instance Peters manner of chalice epic
any animal any and and so on is it's the
result of a very large team as well as
external collaborators that have helped
not only providing data but also
affecting data and help us build and is
five times of relevant I thank you for
your attention and wait for me any
questions thank you dr. AB canes for
that informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
your questions into that box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's take a look
at some of our questions from our
viewers
dr. obtains what is the best
pharmacological assay should one use for
a large-scale drug screening study and
how many replicates so that's a very
good question
ah and there is no good answer to that
one the point is you have to make
trade-offs when you do a very large
scale for screening and you have to use
Isis are fairly simple to implement I'm
using robots so for the moment there are
two main Isis are being you decide to 16
the subtitle diode they look at
different aspects of what makes a cell
viable and the only
generally the only parameters that you
should really
okay is all robust India say when you
implement it you have to do multiple
replicates I switch a three to six
replicates for a specific training
experiment the first June the platform
in a way that you can you can get rid of
reliable cell viability measurements for
some of the drugs known to be either
inactive or very active for different
salons the problem with the turnover
from a logical asset that depending on
the size and depending on the drugs the
mechanics of action could actually
influence the way you want to and when
you do very large still on first
screening studies you don't really have
this it's that flexibility so in in a
sense it really depends on you it really
depends on you on the drugs and make an
action that you want to investigate and
the goal is really to do in Africa case
that is early on to choose the best one
I get for that reliable on surviving
depressions thank you for that dr. ed
canes and besides the pharmaco DB are
there other computational resources to
mine large pharmacogenomic datasets so
there are platforms that have been
developed along the years some of the
auto from the Broad Institute and
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute actually
very interesting that provide additional
analysis tools that are not available in
from a Caribbean for my projects so if
you go on the ccle portal or the gese
Sanger portal you will have access to
those visualization and analysis tools
however from Michael Jackson from of the
DBR the only that from that merge a
large number of updates up to seven
until now but I encourage users to
investigate
tools that have been published by
antiphon yourself for Vegas using the
gbesi data set for instance or
- relieved by the said minor team I
think it's a minor DB - so they are a
jerk there are multiple tools I'm doing
are your suspects of Dionysus and
depending on the analysis you want to do
you may want to its point selected
relevant thank you doctor obtains one
new cancer models such as
patient-derived organoids provide a
better platform for biomarkers discovery
indeed there are many new and some
models are being created to better mimic
on purpose concentrations and and those
are very important initiatives as we
know that cancer sometimes even so they
are very amenable for I through food
drug screening they also have a lot of
factors that make them that make them
behave differently than a chip making
patient body so patient arrived
organized is basically the latest
iteration of of improving cancer models
those are
tumor cells bring as stories readability
recapitulating sometimes part of the
stroma and that was active in the
patient tumors and recent studies have
been shown that those models
recapitulate better was happening the
patient body so no the question is how
do we make those more sophisticated in
vitro models and minimal for large
different response and that's actually
the work there is a lot of work done in
that space and mainly from my fraternity
the welcome for seniors working on a
large under screening platforms for
patient dr organic so the future looks
very bright we are going to have
large-scale from academic data with
better models that hopefully will help
us identify better power markers perk
response
dr. obtain thank you again for your
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 2019 you'll receive an
email from elaborates letting you know
that the webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye